in this video we're going to talk about
how energy is stored in fields and in
particular how if we change the position
of things within that field how it might
change the energy so just as a bit of a
refresher let's remind ourselves what
energy is it is the capacity
to
do
work
and we've also seen that work we can
view it as equal to the magnitude of
force times the displacement in the
direction of that force
and then we can also remind ourselves
what a field is and i'm not just talking
about a big lawn or something like that
a football field i'm talking about a
general idea in physics that's used it's
really just a concept that allows us to
predict and explain how two things that
are not touching each other are still
interacting are still able to exert
forces on each other and in other videos
i've also talked about that really
nothing in this universe is touching we
just conceptualize that sometimes they
are but just as an example of a field we
have an electric field here i could have
done another type of field we could have
done a magnetic field we could have done
a gravitational field although when you
study general relativity which einstein
gave us we realized that it might not
exactly be optimal to co to think about
it as a field but in an electric field
right over here we have a positive
charge we have a negative charge we know
from experience that these two things
attract each other and the convention is
to draw these field lines that go from
the positive towards the negative now if
we were to just let go of these two
point charges over here what would
happen
well we know that due to the electric
field constructed or created or that we
imagine was created by this negative
point charge this positive charge
would have a force acting on it towards
the negative charge and vice versa due
to the electric field that is created by
the positive charge the negative charge
is going to also be attracted to the
positive charge they're both going to
move towards each other
and so when we talk about energy in
fields or energy stored in fields in our
initial configuration how is their
energy just how is their energy in this
field how is their capacity to do work
pause this video and think about that
well think about it this way imagine if
each of these charges were
attached to some type of a mass and let
me do this in a color you can actually
see so let's say that this is towing
some type of a mass
and this is towing some type of a mass
right over here well when you let go and
the forces are exerted on each of these
point charges
assuming that the forces are large
enough they're going to be able to pull
these masses to each towards each other
so there's a potential amount of work
that could be done and it would
essentially keep happening until these
point charges touch and i used air
quotes
with my hand even though you can't see
it or until they can't get any closer to
each other or some other force is
keeping them from getting any closer to
each other so now let me think about how
could i increase the energy that is
stored in this field pause the video and
think about that
well what if i were to keep the positive
charge where it is but if i were to take
the negative charge and if i were to
move it in a direction opposite from the
force direction that the field is trying
to exert so instead of the negative
charge there what if i moved it all the
way out there once again let me do that
in a color you can actually see
well if i moved it out here and we're
still
towing some type of a mass you can see
that when i moved it against the
direction that the the force of the
field is trying to exert that i have
increased the energy in the field
because now i can do more work i can
drag this potential mass over a larger
distance so we have a general principle
here
if we let these charges go in the
direction of the forces that are being
exerted on them due to the field we're
going to reduce the energy in the field
but then if we are able to move them
against the forces of the field and as
you can imagine we're going to have to
put energy into the system to do that
but if we do that then we're storing
more energy in this field because in
that case they're going to be further
away from each other and so they could
drag their little masses that they're
towing even further